I forgot to do something.
No!
Oh well.
Wait!
My time.
I could just do it now.
Oh,
that works.
Actually.
There we go.
Do I want a purple?
No.
Anyway.
Welcome to my baking stream!
I saw someone say that this BGM sounds like Touhou, right?
Doesn't it?
Sounds kind of like a Touhou song.
Oh!
Hold on.
Do you know how to bake?
We're gonna... It doesn't matter.
We're making today chocolate chip cookies.
But what matters the most is...
Is the shape.
Right?
We're gonna make them super spooky.
We're gonna make them...
Whatever we want.
I was thinking a bat.
I was thinking a skeleman.
I was thinking...
A pumpkin.
Whatever we want.
The cookie... I got an amount for...
It was like...
An amount of like 24 cookies.
The secret ingredient is pent of anger.
No, I have a whisk!
I have a whisk!
I'm not gonna use my fists.
Don't worry!
Did you get any specific cookie cutters?
No, no, no.
Cookie cutter?
Today is...
Today is from my sheer brilliance.
Of course.
Of course, of course.
So, hello!
Hello, hello, hello, hello!
Minto shaped cookies.
Ghostly hands.
So spooky, huh?
Did you hear about the B.A.
Idol event?
Idol Mari Reel.
Wait, no I haven't.
But some of these things...
Are...
Look.
Maybe ghost...
Materials.
So, you know.
Even Boo...
He only shows up in certain ways.
But Chibi Minto...
We got a ghost on film.
The invisible man.
Except the invisible maid...
Yeah!
Spooky, huh?
So...
We will be baking.
And I'll be doing my best.
I'm scared because...
Honestly...
Okay, so...
My desk is...
Over here.
And...
So I have to like turn to the side.
For...
Baking.
Hopefully I have enough space.
In fact, I'm gonna move the Hershey's.
Chocolate.
But I got chocolate...
For...
For cookies.
Actually, right now...
Oh gosh.
Right now...
The butter is not yet...
Oh!
I was gonna say it's not yet soft.
But I think it's pretty soft.
Hi, Cookie Minto.
Friendly reminder that raw flour and raw egg can be dangerous.
Okay.
But we're cooking it.
Oh my gosh!
My egg!
Oh, I didn't bring my egg in here.
I have to go get an egg.
Why are her hands like that?
You're pretty cool, Minto.
Thank you.
What's happening?
Why is it weird now?
As soon as I...
What the hell?
What happened?
Did I move my table on accident?
Hold on.
Don't look.
Why is it so scuffed?
I'm literally gonna become the Joker.
I'm going to become the Joker.
Anyway...
Good job.
We live in a society.
I worked so hard!
I'm gonna go get my egg.
Oh, hold on.
Before I do that...
I've got my bowl.
And I'm gonna fill it.
Hold on.
I have like a...
I have...
I have a pre-thing of...
Of baking flour.
And stuff.
Hold on.
Let me pour that in.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, it didn't open it.
Is the music too loud, by the way?
Just let me know.
I ripped it open, but...
I ripped it open, but it didn't work.
What?
I ripped it open, but it's still not open.
The little lines was a lie.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna use my teeth.
Hold on.
I don't have any scissors with me.
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Nice.
It's getting everywhere.
Chibi Minto, don't get dusty, okay?
I think that's enough.
Oh, hold on.
There we go.
It's kind of dusty.
It doesn't look like a cookie.
We're baking the cookies.
What are you talking about?
Okay, now I stir it.
Oh my gosh.
I feel so homely right now.
Nice stealth camo.
Bacon is...
Bacon...
It's actually a bacon.
Like pecan, pecan, it's bacon.
It's a whole different...
stream of...
Okay, so this is...
This is prepared, basically.
I also have my butter.
Okay, let's put in our butter.
Wait, hold on.
Let me read the instructions.
I'm scared.
Okay, I have my oven preheated.
Stir the cookie...
butter...
vanilla egg.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna do like half of the butter and then...
Hopefully my butter is soft enough.
Meeting my first candy cane.
What are you talking about?
It's not candy cane time.
Google the definition of homely real quick.
Wait, what does that mean?
What does a homely mean?
I got it a little bit on me, but that's okay.
Oh my gosh.
Do you guys want to see the most tragic thing ever?
So...
I have this...
I have this cup that I've had for a long time.
It's not even that long though.
I've had mugs that were longer.
Right?
I've had mugs that were around longer.
And they never...
This never happened to them.
But okay, so I have this...
This Idol Master Koume.
Koume...
Idol Master Cinderella Girls.
Koume is like...
She's like the spooky ghost member, you know?
She's like very spooky.
So, you know, I love...
I love anything spooky, you know?
But...
She...
This has never happened to a mug of mine before ever.
Look at this!
This is not just...
Look how...
How...
Faded away it is!
It's the most faded mug I've ever had in my life.
My afterlife.
This never happened before to me.
And I've had it for a while, but like not that long.
I put it in the dishwasher, but this never happened to any of my other mugs before.
It's in character for her, but I can barely even read...
It says like...
Team Cool.
Age 13.
Birthday March 28?
I think that's what it says.
Zodiac sign Aries.
Blood type AB, but you can barely...
I have to squint to read it.
Still usable.
Yeah, but it makes me so sad.
It's like...
She's...
She's disappearing.
Okay.
We put in our butter.
I don't think it's...
Soft enough.
Hold on.
Come out.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Wait, I can't get it out.
I feel like I'm digging in sand right now.
What can I find?
I feel like I'm like...
This is cat litter box simulator.
How do I get it out?
A spoon?
I have a spoon.
Where do I put that?
Okay, I'll put it in the mug.
It's stuck in there!
I guess it's in jail.
That's the jailed butter.
It'll get stirred around eventually.
Probably once I add the egg, it'll become more...
What else do I need to add?
I need to add...
One teaspoon of vanilla.
How much is a teaspoon?
If I just dump it in there, I think it's fine.
Oh, I smell it.
It smells so good.
Like, how much is a teaspoon?
One cap?
You think that's enough?
That's enough?
It smells so good though.
I want my cookies to smell delicious.
Did I change my favorite ringtone?
What did I make?
Are you sure this is enough?
It's not wet at all.
It's so dry.
How am I supposed to make a dough out of this, you guys?
How am I supposed to shape the cookies?
Okay, I forgot my egg in the fridge.
Oh, I forgot also.
I have icing for decorating after.
I have a cookie icing.
Was the butter supposed to be melted?
I said melted, but soft is also melted.
It didn't say to what degree of meltation.
Sorry, Pies is in my room.
Softer.
Did you put in cold butter?
No!
It was definitely squishy.
It may smell good, but if you add too much vanilla, it's going to ruin it.
It's okay, guys.
I'm not going to put in anymore.
It's okay.
Lampy, thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
It kind of looks like melted vanilla ice cream at the moment.
It looks very sandy on my end.
Looks quite sandy.
Use a spatula to stir.
Oh, really?
Okay.
I'm going to go get those things from my kitchen.
The maid cafe kitchen is fully stocked.
I just don't go in there, because I'm a maid cafe maid.
I don't go into the kitchen.
They hand me the food, and then I present it to the guests.
I've never stepped foot in that kitchen before, actually.
Maybe once.
Should I just use my hands?
I think I should use my hands to mix it instead.
Get the egg.
Oh, let me go get my egg.
I'll be right back.
It will probably melt, because my room is so hot.
Everybody!
Okay, collectively...
Start putting, like, fire emoji in the chat.
And it will warm up everything.
Okay, it will melt my butter.
I'll be right back.
I have returned.
It's kind of off, but don't worry about it.
I have returned with a spatula.
And...
An egg!
What if I crushed it?
What if I just...
And just let it seep through my fingers?
What if I...
And then a spatula.
Which kind of looks like a knife.
Are your hands strong enough?
Resist the monkey, resist the crush.
Oh my gosh.
I keep gripping it like I'm really gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it!
This is like the smallest spatula ever.
What are you talking about?
This is so normal!
This is so fun.
Oh shoot.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god, that worked.
Okay, I'm gonna put it in the... Hold on, I need to move the butter.
Where can I put this butter?
Like the butter packaging.
Like this.
Oops, I got some on me.
I have an idea.
I'll put it in that container.
There we go, I'm all good.
Okay, time to crack an egg!
You gotta break an egg to make an omelette, but we're not making an omelette, we're making...
Cookies!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna do it like Ray.
Okay.
Nice crack.
We did that.
Alright.
Oh, spatula.
I'm stabbing, I'm stabbing, I'm stabbing.
Alright, let's absorb.
Oh my god!
It's turning into dough!
We're doing it!
It's really dusty.
Get out of there.
We're okay.
Everything's fine.
Use force.
I'm using force, I'm using force.
Force.
Everything keeps getting stuck in the whisk.
This is the worst thing ever.
Who invented this thing?
I'm gonna go back in time and tell them to fix their creation.
Never patent this.
Ever.
This thing sucks.
This is the worst invention ever!
Use chopsticks.
You're not meant to use a whisk for that.
Yes you are.
Literally every baker has a whisk.
Duh.
Just use your hands?
Maybe.
Maybe I should just use my hands.
Alright everybody.
It's time for the ghost.
Hand special.
We're getting handsy.
Oh boy.
You guys just don't appreciate my art!
What's wrong with my art everybody?
Gosh.
You just don't appreciate it.
Oh I washed my hands.
I washed them.
Don't worry, don't worry.
I keep thinking I'm hearing a cat and it's my cat, but I think it's the BGM.
Alright, I'm just gonna leave this like right here.
Chibi Minto, watch out.
Thank you!
The great Minto Bake Off.
Alright, here we go.
Time to squish it!
I'm nervous!
Wait, I'm scared.
Is this really what bakers do?
Okay.
I'm going in.
I'm scared.
Okay.
It's a rite of passage.
Here we go.
It's getting on my hands a little.
Okay!
We're making progress!
I have to make the dough to make the cookies.
It's okay.
Everybody is...
I'm throwing it at myself.
We're okay.
How do I make it so the other dust gets in with the butter and everything else?
Because my hands are fine!
It's fine!
Don't worry about it!
Okay.
We're still going.
It's still really sandy.
Keep squishing it.
I have to be like a cat.
Like a play-doh.
Oh my god.
It's messy.
Please squish together!
You're family!
You're gonna get baked together!
And it'll taste so good, probably.
Yeah!
Okay.
What if I...
Oh, hold on.
I'm gonna make a patty.
And then I'm gonna put all...
I'm gonna put all the sand inside.
And then...
And then bury it alive.
It's like, okay.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now I roll it.
That didn't work as I intended, but...
Why does it look so dry?
I don't know!
It's just...
What have
I...
I hope these don't...
You guys, I forgot the chocolate chips.
I forgot the chocolate chips.
The most important part.
We're making chocolate chip cookies.
It's okay.
It's just like I've been to the beach.
A little bit.
Okay.
Milk?
No, that's not what the recipe calls for.
I'm following the recipe!
I'm so glad I put stuff down on my floor.
So that if I make a mess...
It catches it.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know how much a cup is.
Maybe like that much.
Maybe.
More?
Less?
Maybe like that much.
Maybe.
More.
Sand!
I feel like...
Oh my gosh.
I feel like those commercials of the children that get those sandy...
Like...
Oh my gosh.
It's still so sandy.
Those...
Moon sand!
Yes!
You okay, Chibi Minto?
She says yep.
All good, baby.
All good.
How we doing, everybody?
So then after we do this...
After we do this, we'll shape it...
Into fun shapes.
And they'll bake...
And they'll become those shapes.
I think I'm gonna make a 3D witch.
If I make a cookie that's standing up...
Like...
Like yay high...
With a hat and everything.
How will it cook?
Today we'll find out.
It will work.
What if I put toothpicks in it?
It will melt?
No, no, no.
What if I put toothpicks in it?
Are you tempted to eat the cookie dough right away?
No.
I'm squishing it.
I'm tempted to...
Wait, this is actually becoming so good.
Look guys, it's a real dough.
The character of steam dolls.
Oh, I have heard about that.
We have dough!
We have liftoff!
Yeah!
Oh, it's a little...
Oh god, hold on.
It's still a little dry.
It's okay though.
Also, you guys kept saying gloves.
These are my hands, so...
Rude.
You probably just think I have such pretty hands...
That it looks like gloves.
But it's not.
It's actually my hands.
You know?
I'm a ghost.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Real dough!
Guys, we did it!
We did it!
Okay, this was truly a trust the process sort of moment.
This is truly a trust the process.
But wait, did you guys trust?
Did you guys trust?
Alright.
Next, I have to transfer...
Hold on, what if I get everything off of this?
Take that.
Let's get everything in here.
Get out.
Get out and smoosh.
Smoosh.
You guys trusted the process.
Uh-oh, there's cat hair.
Uh-oh.
Don't worry about it.
I won't use that bit.
Guys, this is just what happens when you live with a cat, okay?
It's literally cat hair everywhere, okay?
You have to understand.
It gives it kick.
Okay, now I should have...
Oh, what is this?
I got stuff on me.
Okay, I think it's butter.
Now that I have this, I'm gonna put these away.
Don't need my whisk or my spatula anymore.
In fact, I didn't need them to begin with.
You guys are gonna be so excited to see this.
I have...
Hold on, I gotta open it.
Here we go.
I have special plates that we can put our cookies on before I put them on the pan.
So I can get rid of my bowl.
Wait.
Let me just take...
I'm just gonna move it.
Alright.
Okay.
Yeah!
Happy Halloween!
Okay, oh wait.
So now we're gonna start making one...
One cookie at a time.
Pick number three, my lord.
My lord.
Okay,
I'm gonna put... We're gonna do it in little chunks at a time.
So this is our first cookie chunk.
And the rest goes on another plate.
Then I have to find a place to let it sit.
Oh, no.
That's my mic.
There we go.
Alright.
So, we have our cookie chunk.
What kind of first cookie should we make?
It could be a bat.
It could be a ghost.
It could be a witch.
It could be a pumpkin.
It could be anything.
A spider?
A wisp?
Okay.
It could be anything we want!
The world is our oyster, but I'm not making that.
Should we do a wisp first?
Okay.
Alright.
This one's gonna be easy though, right?
Okay, he's got a little bit of a thing there.
My genius will guide us to victory in this turn.
So it's like that.
Just like that, right?
And he's got little cat ears.
Yep, there we go.
One ear.
Oh my gosh!
This looks so good!
Oh, is it too chunky?
It's okay, I gotta have a big chunk to spread out.
Or to... Here, see?
Like this.
See?
He becomes bigger.
And we need more... We need the material.
See?
It looks just like you guys!
It's gotta have a tip.
I think that'll fry off.
Nah.
Okay.
It's gonna be raw?
Okay, I have to tear you in half, guys.
We can't have it be raw.
Redo.
Good base.
This is a good base.
Like that.
Okay.
Now, from here...
From here, that's like your ear.
Hold on, parts of it are getting on me.
Okay.
See?
Can't believe she ripped us in half.
I've done it before and I'll do it again.
Okay.
And how am I supposed to form your ears?
If I don't have enough dough!
Oh wait, just like that.
You guys are coming apart in my hands a little bit.
It's okay.
I'll cradle you.
Just like that!
Oh my gosh, it looks so good actually!
Do a rolling pin and knife?
No.
I don't have space for that really.
Okay, now I'm gonna give you guys eyes.
How do I do your mouth?
V-shape?
Okay.
Like that?
Like that!
It's cute, right?
Yeah!
Okay, what's wrong with your eye?
What are you talking about?
Oh my precious little wisp.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna bake you up and I'm gonna eat you.
Okay, that's one cookie down.
That was easy though.
That was an easy cookie.
I need to transfer him to a plate.
Oh wait, maybe to the cooking... baking pan.
I have no more space.
I'm afraid of putting it where I want to put it.
Because I think pies will try to eat it.
Are you calling wisps simple or something?
No, no, no,
no.
Just put it on the baking sheet?
Yeah, but I don't have a place to put the baking sheet.
Currently it's up sideways against...
Here, actually I'll keep it in my lap.
Come here.
Okay, say goodbye.
Next time you see him, he'll be a fully fledged cookie.
Oh man.
Wow!
Okay, alright, next.
Oh, okay, I can't work in these conditions.
I caved immediately.
Hold on, I didn't...
Okay,
we're good.
Alright, what should we shape next?
I'm thinking maybe a skelly... a skelly-ton.
How do you guys think?
A skelly-ton.
Spooky!
Okay, this... Oh my gosh!
I basically made a skelly-ton.
Wait!
Am I a genius?
Do you see it?
I basically already made one.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
It's a skelly-ton with a lobotomy, which doesn't make much sense, cause...
You know.
Cause skelly-tons don't have brains.
But...
Okay, for this one we're gonna call out our trusty spatula.
Perfect!
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Trust the process!
Trust the process.
I gotta get my little finger in there.
I just gotta...
I just gotta do this a little bit in their eyes.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, good.
Hold on, it's a little lopsided.
Actually that looks pretty good.
What do you guys think?
It's pretty good.
It looks good.
Where's the skeleton teeth?
I'm not there yet!
I'm not there yet.
That's where the spatula comes in.
Kinda looks like Cthulhu.
It's pretty cute though, right?
It's okay that his head is lumpy.
It's like a lumpy skull, just like mine.
That I used to have.
I see Cthulhu.
Cthulhu's spooky too though.
I think it's okay.
I'm digging out his eye holes.
Hold on, I gotta get there with a personal touch.
Okay.
Alright, let's move him to the cookie pan.
Say goodbye.
To our guy, say goodbye.
To Freddy Fazbear.
Okay, we can do Freddy Fazbear.
Okay.
Alright, time for Freddy Fazbear.
I don't have a reference picture, so it will be Freddy Fazbear from memory.
Thank you!
Sorry that Chibi Minto is becoming a little more ghostly.
As time goes on.
Chibi Minto, are you okay?
There you go.
She says, I'm fine.
Don't worry about me.
I'm just traveling through inter...
Oh, I probably shouldn't touch her with my gloves.
That's okay, Chibi Minto needs a shower anyway.
Okay.
Freddy Fazbear!
Freddy Fazbear from memory.
Freddy Fazbear has a hat.
Freddy Fazbear has a bow tie.
Freddy Fazbear has a...
What gloves?
Oh, the gloves that I have on my hand for touching all this stuff.
You guys, these are my real hands, but of course I'm wearing gloves.
I'm wearing rubber gloves right now.
You just can't see them.
They're ghosts.
Ghost gloves.
The real GGs.
What, do you think I'm some kind of monster?
Touching this without any protection?
Who do you... I mean, I am a monster, but who do you take me for?
Dead.
Okay.
Freddy Fazbear.
If I wasn't making a sentence of Freddy Fazbear, this would be such a good looking cookie.
Hi, Pies!
You're looking at the cookie.
Wait, did you... Why are you licking your lips?
I think the cookies are safe.
Are you good?
Yeah?
You're being a licky, licky girl.
Okay, I think we're okay.
Jack from Nightmare Before Christmas?
We just did a skeleton, though.
Okay, I think we're fine.
I think it's fine.
Alright, Freddy Fazbear.
Corin, thank you!
That was a little Corin.
We would have a big spooky Halloween party with decorations and a smoke machine.
With all the other kids, the big event at the end was decorating Halloween sugar cookies.
So Halloween cookies are part of my core memory.
Happy that I can help out.
Okay, I'm gonna lobotomize Freddy Fazbear.
This is our base Freddy.
This is the base Freddy.
Also, once we put the cookies in the oven, maybe I'll show you guys.
Pause, okay?
Oh, nose, ear.
Ears and a nose.
Yeah, yeah, he has those too.
Okay, this is gonna be our hat.
This is gonna be our top hat.
It's gotta be flat and big.
Oh my goodness.
Does that look like a top hat to you guys?
Does that look good?
Pies reveal.
Does this look good to you guys?
Yeah?
Perfect?
Good.
It's looking just like him!
Oh my gosh, and I already have the ears kind of poking out here.
Everybody say whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore.
Now for Freddy's ears and nose, we're gonna have to...
We're gonna have to give him some chocolates.
This might be Glamrock Freddy because he's already looking so fabulous.
Oh my gosh!
He's looking good.
Wait, what?
Freddy Fazbear has a big ol' smile.
Spatula time.
Oh yeah!
No, this is a spatula, not a knife.
Oh yeah, baby.
Freddy Fazbear is ready for some children's entertainment.
Whore, whore, whore, whore.
You can tell it's him, right?
Yeah, you can tell it's Freddy Fazbear.
Whore, whore, whore, whore, whore.
Okay, say goodbye to Freddy Fazbear.
Bye Freddy.
He's going to the...
He's going to the cookie pan.
Guys, I think I only have enough room on my cookie pan for like six cookies.
So we'll do six and then we'll bake them up, baby.
Hold on.
I gotta use the spatula to get them off.
He's really fragile.
Freddy!
Before I bake them, I'll fix them up.
Don't worry.
Perfect Paddington.
No Paddington!
Casualty!
We're good.
Let's get some more dough, baby.
Okay.
I got my dough.
What should we make?
A bat?
Okay, we can do a bat.
Hiya!
Paz is watching like, what the hell are you doing?
You're so cute, little girl.
You're so cute.
Okay.
Here is a bat.
So far.
Alright, this one we're actually going to cut out.
I know I said I was going to go off on my sheer genius before, but this time we're cutting.
Oh boy.
This is why I didn't cut before.
It looks like stupid ass.
God dammit.
What does a bat look like?
Okay, hold on.
I have an image.
He's got little ears.
Okay.
Like that?
Oh, thanks for the references, you guys.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
It might have, like, not a lot of body.
But that's okay.
Bats come in all shapes and sizes.
And he's got to have a little butt body.
Yeah, I can add that in with the extra.
Okay, it's a little rough.
But when we get him out of the oven...
When we get him out of the oven, we'll decorate him with some icing.
Really
nicely here.
To let everybody know that he's a friendly guy.
We'll give him a big ol' face.
Kind of looks like the Mothman.
Real
tears.
I think he'll bake into his body, you know?
He's not looking so great right now, but...
It's kind of like when a kid is ugly and has a little bit of a glow up.
I think that's what will happen.
Yeah, he's a grower.
He's a grower.
Bake these cookies until they're boneless.
They don't have bones already.
Oh my gosh.
I'm crying real tears.
Oh, you can't see.
You can't see.
Okay.
Alright, everybody say goodbye to Batman.
Mothman.
Batman.
Everybody say goodbye.
He's going to the...
Neocraft!
Thank you for the deck gift.
Thank you.
He's going to the baking sheet.
Just got my nails in your color.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Bye Batman.
Next time you see him, he'll be really big and strong.
Getting
these guys off the plate is like impossible.
What
is our next cookie design?
Did you grease the baking sheet?
It doesn't say to... Oh yeah.
Place two inches apart on an ungreased cookie sheet.
It's okay.
The direction says ungreased.
What is this?
What is that?
That's cookie dough.
Yeah, little girl.
She's so curious.
She's just been non-stop staring.
She loves to jump on top of high places.
And I had a box.
Actually, the box that someone gifted me from Off-Kai.
It was like the Minto love box.
I had that set up with a bag on top of it and she would like run and jump on top of it and everything.
But she started... It started to break.
Because of how aggressive she was jumping on top of it because she was so excited about it.
And so now she has a smaller box.
I feel really bad.
But she just loves jumping on top of like a box.
She's such a good girl.
Does she have a scratching post?
She has multiple scratching posts.
Ashes!
It means I love you but I'm starting to lose faith in the process.
Why?
Hold on.
This pumpkin will convince you otherwise.
This is gonna be a grand pumpkin.
Hold on, first we gotta get into pumpkin shape.
Tip-top pumpkin shape.
Look how delicate I'm being like a real baker.
Oh, that's a pumpkin shape.
I'm ready to be a believer.
Believers in the chat, rise up!
Believers in the chat.
Oh my god, if this were like a done cookie, it would look kind of insane.
But it's not.
It's not supposed to be normal.
It's supposed to be a pumpkin.
So we're gonna... We're gonna inject... We're gonna indent, I mean, sorry, English.
We're gonna... make him even more lumpy.
And then we're also gonna add a little tuft at the top.
And then I saw her bake.
You're the greatest baker I've ever witnessed.
Thanks, Tia!
See, Tia knows who owns her.
Okay.
That looks like a pumpkin.
Should we do one?
Maybe the... What expression should we do?
Let's... Okay, first we gotta do triangle eyes.
It's hard with the... It's really hard with the...
Cook... Chocolate chips in there.
Because it makes it really lumpy.
So it's honestly not even my fault.
It's actually the chocolate...
Chip situation going on in there.
Process is quite something.
Good!
Can you do a snake animal next?
Looks like my peanuts.
No!
It's a pumpkin, not peanuts.
Hold on, he's just a little...
He's just got a little bit of...
I just gotta get my fingers in there.
Who said all pumpkins need to have triangle eyes?
Some of them have...
Round eyes.
Pies, what do you think?
She's stretching like a typical black cat.
Like you know how you see a Halloween decoration of a black cat stretching?
That's what she looks like right now.
Oops!
Don't worry about it.
See, that's a chocolate chip.
That's why it was so difficult to get it out, you know?
It looks like a pumpkin still.
Maybe the stalk is too tall.
There we go!
That looks like a pumpkin.
By the way, in this in tears list, from pumpkin to squash, I'm leaning more towards squash.
What about now?
More pumpkin than squash.
More pumpkin than squash, I'd say.
It's not my fault the dough gets all over my hands.
Okay, now what kind of mouth should he have?
What kind of mouth do we want him to have?
We can have him like the one right next to me.
X mouth.
Smile.
Get out of the way chocolate chip cookie.
You guys!
Oh wait, colon three?
I can see it, I'm sorry for doubting the process.
It's okay.
We have to go to Waffle House eventually.
And fight.
Hold on, there's like a big old chocolate chip right there.
What about that?
What about like that?
Does that look good to you guys?
Okay.
Everybody say goodbye to Mr. Pumpkin!
He's gone through some troubles along the way.
He's winking vertically.
It's his battle scar, okay?
Alright, everybody say bye to Mr. Pumpkin.
Okay, we can do one more before I put them in the oven.
And then the rest I'm gonna make normally.
The rest, I still have...
Look guys, look how much dough we have left.
I'm gonna make normal cookies too.
Just like a little plop, plop, plop.
But I don't know what to do with them.
I'm gonna have cookies for days.
Mr. Punished Pumpkin.
A spitter?
That's pretty spooky.
Okay, we've done...
Wait, I have to do my 3D witch?
We've done a bat, we've done a skeleton, we've done Freddy Fazbear, we've done...
A wisp, we've done a pumpkin.
This is hard.
What else is so Halloween, you know?
But that's so close to the wisps.
No?
She looked at me when I did that.
Sorry girl.
You're so silly.
Why are you looking at me like that?
A ghost.
We've got that right here.
A goblin.
How do I even make a goblin?
How do I make a goblin?
Okay, we'll do a spider.
Everybody's saying spider, so...
We'll do a spider.
This might be my magnum opus.
This will be the greatest one.
Okay.
This is gonna be...
Alright, we're gonna make him kinda big too.
I might need a second cookie sheet.
Okay.
Because he's gonna have mandibles and thoraxes and...
Everything like that, you know?
Okay, so we're gonna...
Tear this off and we're gonna make this into the spider body.
Into the spider-verse.
Okay.
Alright.
If you can get a little cookie in the oven and not just eat all the dough and feel sick...
Then you're doing better than me.
Why do you eat the dough for?
They sell...
Actually, when I was at the grocery store...
I was like...
I was like, I don't wanna make my...
I don't wanna have completely pre-made cookie dough.
You know what I mean?
That's no fun.
But they sell ones that are like...
This is cookie dough and you can eat it as a raw cookie dough.
Which I thought was kinda crazy.
Might have been safer for me.
Okay.
Spiders are a little...
Oblong.
They're a little oval.
Like so.
Oh wait, hold on.
Actually, this part is supposed to be the smallest.
Smaller, smaller, smaller!
Right?
Isn't this part the smallest and then their butt is huge?
It's just the egg.
Egg is what makes it dangerous.
Also flour too though, right?
Yeah, because raw flour...
Yeah, raw flour is not safe to consume.
And raw egg is not safe to consume.
Depending on where you are.
Some places raw egg is okay.
But...
I think flour is worse than the egg.
To be honest.
What if you just washed the outside of your egg?
Would it then be okay?
Why is this one so fat?
Look how fat this cookie is.
Oh no, it makes it worse?
Wait, why would washing the egg make it worse?
How does that work?
Okay.
We have the body...
The head and the body...
Of the spider.
We've got it, we've got it.
Okay.
I'm gonna give him some eyes.
The egg is handling things.
Washing then takes the waxy layer off.
We wash our eggs in the US.
That's why we refrigerate our eggs.
It removes the protective membrane.
Oh...
So it's the membrane.
The membrane being gone.
Oh...
Interesting.
Yeah, and then the bacteria gets in because the membrane is gone.
You can...
Just be careful if you eat raw eggs.
If you're in the US, you know.
Let's give him a little smile.
A little smile guy.
Oh, he looks so cute!
Oh, he looks so precious.
Okay, now time to give him legs so he can move around.
Creepy crawly.
Who's eating raw eggs?
Because you would be surprised...
There's a lot of people that eat raw eggs.
For whatever reason.
Like in their...
People that are...
Isn't that like a thing with like guys that are at the gym?
They eat the raw eggs.
They're just like, yeah, gotta eat the raw eggs.
Them gym bros.
Yeah, the gym bros.
Okay.
Actually, this might use on the rest of the dough, I wonder.
We got this.
He might have to get his own...
Thing.
His own...
His own cookie platter.
Oh,
coming apart in my hands.
I have to put two more legs on.
Each side.
I have to put on four more legs.
Bing.
We'll make them smaller.
Okay.
Good.
Good, good, good.
Good, good.
I don't really have room.
Oh gosh, I don't really have room.
He has one...
The butt leg.
Zoinks, Scoob.
She's dead.
Zoinks.
At the front?
Oh yeah, true, true.
Like off his face, right?
These aren't really legs, but they kind of look like they could be.
Like so.
Okay.
It's not really a leg.
Here, I'll give him a butt leg and then he lost one in the war, okay?
I kind of want to give him a top hat.
Okay, I'm going to give him a top hat.
Okay, hold on.
It's going to be 3D top hat.
This is some high class...
Bakery...
Sorcery here, okay?
This is a skill that you should not try at home, okay?
Only do it in the presence of a trained professional, okay?
Get
a little smaller.
It's kind of thick.
What do you want, girly girl?
What are you looking at me for?
Why did you get up?
I have to redo it.
He's gorgeous.
Yeah, Cookie Master's only.
I think she wants out.
Oh, she knows it's ready to bake.
She knows it's time to bake, baby.
Okay.
7 legs.
Yeah, because he lost one in the war.
How many times do I have to tell you?
He lost it in the war.
He lost it.
Look at this little top hat.
Look how precious that is.
Okay.
Yeah, he's got a phantom limb.
He's got that phantom pain, baby.
Okay.
Well, this is going to be...
It's going to take me a couple of minutes to get them all in the oven.
Let me see how long they need to bake.
10 to 12 minutes.
Until the edges are light golden brown.
So I'm probably...
Yeah, I'll go periodically check on them.
But it's going to take me a few minutes to get it in the oven.
So...
Oh, wait.
No, it's fine.
6 legs plus 1.
No, it's 7 legs.
And then he has lost one in the war.
Okay.
Okay, so give me a few minutes.
Oh, hold on.
Everybody say...
Goodbye to Mr. Spider.
I have important information regarding Tobey Crier Resident Evil 4.
No!
Alright, say goodbye to Mr. Spider.
He's going back to war!
Oh my god, this is such a heavy play.
Okay, he's going to get his own cookie sheet.
About...
I don't know how long.
I don't want to rush myself.
So just give me a few minutes.
Here, I'm going to put this cookie dough here.
This is all we got left.
After the spider incident.
Crazy.
Okay.
Are you guys excited to see how things are going to turn out?
Did you preheat the oven?
I did, I did, I did.
So, we're good.
Alright.
Give me a minute.
Oh my goodness, I need to wash my hands too.
My hands are so greasy.
Give me a minute.
BRB
Oh, let me make a little message.
Let me type up a message.
I'm going to have to clean up my desk after this.
Oh, I didn't want to type on the keyboard.
Oh no.
I didn't want to type on the keyboard.
Oh well.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Ew, my mouth.
Oh gosh, it feels so gross.
Okay.
Alright.
BRB!
Alright, let me make a timer for 10 minutes.
Let's make a timer for 10 minutes.
Ew, my mouth is greasy.
Oh gosh.
Okay, welcome back.
Thank you.
Alright.
10 minutes.
Copy.
Okay.
This one.
Start.
It says starting, but don't...
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, can I change it?
Can I lick the spoon?
No, I put it in the sink already.
This is a great spooky stream because you created some truly horrifying creatures and nightmares.
Thank you!
Spooky, spooky.
And then afterwards, you guys... Hold on, let me put my...
Let me... Oh gosh.
I'm gonna put the chocolate here.
I have to put my grease back on.
Hold on.
What was I gonna say?
Oh, we have to ice it after.
Love the BGM.
I know, it's so fun, right?
It's called...
I downloaded it from Dova Syndrome.
Halloween no yakusoku, I think.
It was.
Okay.
And after, we...
Ice it!
After we ice it, we're gonna put some icing on.
Cookie icing.
I only got white.
Can I lick the gloves?
They smell really good.
They're not gloves, they're my hands.
But they smell really good.
My hands smell really good.
What's the icing like, I wonder.
Let's open it up and see.
I have to open it, open it.
Wait a second.
The seal?
Is this okay?
The seal is like up here.
But this is...
When I unscrewed it...
The seal came off.
Like it's...
It's there.
That's the seal.
It's supposed to be on top of this part.
What if someone licked in there?
Maybe it's just a loose seal.
Isn't that dangerous?
I licked it.
It was me.
What if someone filmed it on TikTok?
Oh my gosh, everybody...
Look up TikTok licking the Halloween icing and tell me if you find anything.
Is it crusty?
No, it smells really good.
It's probably just a loose seal, right?
Loose seal ball.
It's probably fine.
Okay, I have to get the seal out though somehow.
I don't know how to get it out.
Use the spatula?
But the spatula has egg on it.
This is meant for...
The finished cookies.
I know toothpaste that unseals when you unscrew the cap.
Oh, maybe.
But then how do I...
I don't think that's this.
Oh, clean plate?
Yeah, you're so right.
A clean plate!
We did it!
I'm a genius, probably.
Maybe I need to get a fork.
Okay, we'll try it.
We'll get it open.
We'll get it open...
When...
We get the cookies in 5 minutes.
Oh my gosh, are you guys excited to see our cookies?
Are you guys excited?
Still got the spoon handy?
No...
I threw it away.
In the sink, not in the garbage.
Oh my gosh, I want to see Frebby.
Frebby...
You got oven mitts ready?
Oh yeah!
Our cookies are baking now, everybody!
We have 4 minutes and 20 seconds until our cookies are completed.
And...
I guess I won't be able to eat them right away because I need to cool just a little bit.
But...
We will be able to see them.
And how amazing they look.
I'm scared.
Guys, this is like my first time ever shaping cookies and baking them.
Ever, ever, ever.
And I have it all...
All on camera.
BGM sounds like a Halloween version of Suika Ibuki's theme.
I can hear... Wait, how does Suika's theme...
Oh, I hear it, actually.
I hear it.
Whenever I'm like, how does Suika's theme go...
I think of...
Petan.
Your creepies look like creepy pasta.
Oh, I mean creepies of my cookies.
You might want to check the cookies early as the timing can vary.
Can we eat leftover cookie dough?
No!
No, it has...
It has...
Egg!
It's not good, it's not good.
It's not good, it's not good for you.
And it's got raw flour.
It's not good for you.
No, no.
Unsafe flour.
Unsafe flour!
We literally just had this whole conversation!
Okay, I'll check them.
Should I go check them now?
Doesn't feel like it's been 10 minutes.
I'm scared.
Yeah?
Okay, I'm gonna go check them.
I'm gonna go check them.
I'm gonna go check them real quick.
I'll be right back.
I'm scared!
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Actually, it's been over a little bit.
It's been actually like over 10 minutes because I...
Put them in the oven and I forgot to...
I don't know what time I...
And I forgot to make a timer.
Okay, I'm gonna go check.
Okay.
So...
Bad news.
I...
Thought they were done.
And I took them out.
And I tried to put them on a plate.
And...
They crumpled.
So they're back in the oven.
They're back in the oven.
But only two of them crumpled.
It was...
The pumpkin and...
Mothman.
That's just the way.
Gotta let them sit.
Oh, so you think that they're done?
Is the spider okay?
Yeah, I haven't touched him.
In fact, he looks really great.
Okay, I wasn't gonna experiment with him.
Cookies need several minutes to firm up once done.
Both.
They cool and harden.
Let me...
Let me go get them out!
Hold on, let me go...
Let me go get them out.
Oh god, they're gonna burn!
Our cookies are cooling.
Cool...
Cooling...
Down.
Let's do...
Let's do like five...
Oops.
Five minutes of cool.
Then I'll go check on them.
Cooling down.
Oh, they're cool.
They're cool as a cucumber.
Yeah.
They need to...
They need to chill.
Like, yeah.
They were up...
They were like crazy.
They were like way up there.
And now they're cooling.
They're coming down.
They're cooling down.
Oh my gosh.
Hope Mr. Pumpkin is doing well.
He only suffered a little minor injury.
Moth...
No, I mean...
The bat, he kind of broke in half.
But, I think it's okay.
Maybe I should have...
I tried to squish him back together a little bit.
They're looking really fantastic.
I'm sure you can guess.
They look really scrumptious.
Scrumptious...
Oh yeah.
Glue them back together with icing.
Yeah.
I'm not quite sure...
How easy it will be to get them off the baking sheet...
To decorate them.
But...
Late to the stream.
What kind of cookies are these?
They're chocolate chip cookies.
But they're spooky Halloween shapes that I made with my own hands.
Very special.
Very, very good.
How about the spider?
He looks amazing, actually.
Spider looks so good.
Hidden raisins?
No!
Only chocolate.
I still have a little bit of dough left.
I might make something else later on off stream.
Who knows?
No, I didn't burn them!
They're good, they're good.
Actually, when I opened the door, I was like...
This smells like a wonderland.
It smells so good.
I swear, I swear, I swear.
Maybe I should have put them outside.
Maybe I should have put them outside to cool faster.
It's probably fine.
Raisin cookies?
Doko?
Not Coco.
Raisin cookies, out of here.
Actually, I love oatmeal raisin cookies.
Yeah.
This pie is already snacking on them.
No, she's a good girl.
She's a good girl.
What's your favorite kind of cookie?
I think mine...
I don't know, it depends on if I really want sweet or not.
Peanut butter?
Peanut butter's...
Your name is literally...
Crunchy PBJ.
Oatmeal raisin are great cookies.
Yeah!
I bet the cookies will truly...
Will look truly three spooky five us.
Are you guys feeling the Halloween spirit?
Are you guys feeling it?
Are you guys like...
Oh my gosh.
It is truly Halloween now that we're making Halloween cookies.
Yeah!
It's Halloween time!
The Halloween spirit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kinda spooked, not gonna lie.
I mean...
It's the time where the dimensions...
Are...
For the spirits...
To come.
Is that what they say?
If you didn't take them out, they are still cooking.
No, I took them out, I took them out.
The veil is thinnest.
Yeah, the veil is thinnest.
For the ghosts to wander into the human realm.
But I'm always...
Basically...
Well, I'm like, you know...
I'm digital, it's like a weird...
I'm like a ghost in the machine.
Guys, I'm nervous.
I'm nervous about my cookies.
Oh my gosh.
I was talking with my rigor today.
Welcome to Mambo's help.
Thanks for the two months.
Thanks, gift.
Thanks whoever gifted you for two months.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
Right before this I met with...
Yeah, the person doing my rigging and...
We were sorting stuff out.
So...
Exciting, exciting.
Stuff is happening.
Sure, I love you.
Thanks for four months.
Let's go.
Okay, I'm gonna go check on...
Wait, let me update the message.
Cookies are cool.
Let me go check on them.
Sorry, I know I keep having to step away so much.
I'm sorry guys.
Thank you so much for the message.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Okay, I'll be right back.
Everybody, I have our cookies!
I have our cookies!
Please!
One moment, please!
Oh my gosh.
Did they survive after cooling?
We had a bit of an incident.
But most of them survived.
Most of them survived.
One incident happened which was very sad.
I was very sad.
But that's okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna start off with our losers.
The initial two that broke in the process of getting them from point A to point B.
Oh wait, no, this was when they were first cooling.
When I didn't let them cool long enough.
So I would like to welcome...
Wait, pumpkin on the left.
I don't really need to explain this because you'll be able to tell, I'm sure.
Pumpkin on the left.
Bat on the right.
You can see...
They had a little bit of an accident.
They're not raw!
Which is which?
Pumpkin.
Bat.
They're burnt.
No!
Pumpkin.
Bat.
This is...
This is them.
I see Blob and Blorb.
Okay, hold on.
The rest look amazing, I promise you.
Let's go with the next two.
Have you seen a bat before?
Yes!
It kind of looked more like a mothman, but you know.
Alright, our next two.
Is Skeleton and Freddy Fazbear.
I
love this
skull.
You can kind of see it.
It looks like his eyes are really tight.
Tightly shut.
Freddy looks really dashing though.
I'm really proud of that one.
I'm really proud of that one of Freddy Fazbear.
It looks so much like him.
I'm just gonna put them on top of each other.
Okay.
Next is, of course, I must show off you guys.
Our little wisp.
Are you ready?
The wisp somehow...
The eyes moved places and also...
He grew a nose.
The eyes really moved places a lot.
This one candy is really good, right?
It's actually really good.
Can I eat this one right now?
If I eat this one, can I eat it right now?
Or should we wait for the icing?
And last, but not least.
The grand finale.
With the top hat.
As dashing as his smile.
A Facebook Dover.
Thank you.
Spider.
Which he did have some incidents.
He kind of broke into too many pieces.
When I was...
When I was moving him.
Okay.
Introducing...
Spider.
He looks like Flatbug Friday.
Spider Blob.
Well, guys.
What a treat.
A lot of comments.
And you can even still see his top hat.
Hold on.
His top hat is still there.
Guys, it made it.
Oh, SCMD.
Oh my gosh, it's your birthday.
Happy birthday.
Sorry, I missed it.
The top hat made it.
That's an amazing cookie rendition of the monster from John Connor.
There's the thing.
He's really precious.
I'm so happy about him.
It's like one of those like smiles that only you can see.
Where he like broke off.
Here, but that's okay.
Even he's got...
It looks like he's got like a fedora.
The spider brought tears to my eyes.
Thanks, vent, of course.
There's...
I don't even know if I want to decorate them.
I honestly feel like they're perfect as it is.
I'm honestly feeling that they're just really lovely as they are.
Let me try to... Okay, I don't want to eat him.
Time to eat the wisp.
Itadakimasu!
Yummy!
I think I am a real baker!
One more.
One more bite.
A success!
Yes.
What's that taste?
It's like salty.
Have you guys been crying too much?
You're making your little body salty.
Why is everything black?
Your eyes are right there.
If anything, I just kind of...
I gave you like a sculpting, you know?
I gave you a real chiseled...
What's the word?
Cheekbone right there.
Oh no, she ate us.
Did you swap the sugar for salt?
No, I think it's your tears.
First Mint Phantom to eat tomorrow.
She ate us!
Yay, success everybody!
Success!
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Which is your favorite cookie?
I think mine is the spider.
But I'm also really a big fan of Freddy Fazbear.
You know what Freddy looks like?
He kind of looks like that...
What was that scary story to tell in the dark?
That lady that has the long hair.
The Wisp is your favorite?
Fredby and Spider.
The lady in white kind of looks like her.
Kind of looks like her.
Yeah.
Oh, I meant losing consciousness because you ate us.
I gotcha.
Spider is a real treat though.
Oh my goodness.
I'm so happy they turned out really well.
Yay!
Well guys, I think today's stream is a bit of a shorter stream.
But I feel really happy about the cookies we baked.
So, thanks for joining me on my first ever baking adventure.
Thank you.
I gotta wash my hands like real good now and I gotta clean up everything.
And I still have this dough here.
That I gotta do something with.
Thank you guys!
This girl I like was extra cute today.
How do I handle this?
Ducky!
Thanks for the 5 Gupta!
Were we cheating on Minto?
I'm just a ghost man.
Thanks for the fun stream.
I hope you guys had fun.
I hope you guys... This is your reminder.
Trust the process.
Thanks for the 5 Gupta!
Trust... Oh, show pause?
Oh, she's not in here.
My hands are greasy.
I don't wanna pick her up with greasy hands.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can go find her.
One second.
I'll go find her.
She's so cute.
You're so so cute.
Hold on.
Let me find where she is.
Everybody wants to see you.
Thanks for the 5 Gupta!
Thank you for the 5 Gupta!
Have a good night!
Thank you!
Oh, wait.
Let me make sure...
I forgot to check something.
Yeah, okay.
Bye bye!